♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ANOTHER MIGRANT
CARAVAN FROM CENTRAL AMERICA
MAKING ITS WAY TO OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, IT'S A MASS OF ABOUT A
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THEY CROSSED FROM HONDURAS INTO
GUATEMALA.
IF THE PRESIDENT RESPONDED ON
TWITTER TO ALL OF THIS.
HE SAID "THE UNITED STATES HAS
STRONGLY INFORMED THE
PRESIDENT OF HONDURAS AT THE
LARGE CARAVAN OF PEOPLE HEADED
TO THE U.S. IS NOT STOPPED AND
BROUGHT BACK, NO MORE MONEY OR
IT WILL BE GIVEN TO HONDURAS
EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY.
THAT THREAT MAY HAVE WORKED IN
THE SHORT TERM, GUATEMALA
AUTHORITIES SAY THEY HAVE
ARRESTED THE LEADER AND HAVE
DEPORTED HIM BACK TO HONDURAS.
WELL VERSED IN INTERNATIONAL LAW
AND THE POLITICS OF CENTRAL
AMERICA, HE IS A REGISTERED
FOREIGN AGENT FOR THE GOVERNMENT
OF EL SALVADOR.
WHY IS THAT NOT EXACTLY THE
RESPONSE EVERY PRESIDENT OUGHT
TO GIVE ONE A FOREIGN COUNTRY
ATTEMPTS A KIND OF INVASION.
>> WE HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
PROTECT OUR BORDER AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO LET ANY OF THESE
MIGRANTS IN.
IF THE GOAL IS FOR THEM NOT TO
COME HERE, WE SHOULD NOT BE
CUTTING OFF FOREIGN AID TO
HONDURAS.
HONDURAS IS GETTING THAT AID AND
WE CAN HELP IMPROVE THE ECONOMY.
THE REASON THESE PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING HONDURAS IS BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY IS TERRIBLE IN THERE ARE
NO JOBS.
THESE ARE ECONOMIC REFUGEES AND
THE REASON THEY ARE TRYING TO
COME TO THE U.S. IS THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR A BETTER LIFE.
IN THE LONG TERM IF WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO COME WE HAVE TO TRY
TO WORK WITH HONDURAS AND THE
OTHER COUNTRIES IN
CENTRAL AMERICA TO IMPROVE THEIR
ECONOMIES SO PEOPLE STAY.
>> Tucker: HOW IS THAT WORKING
FOR US?
WE'VE GIVEN A LOT OF AID TO
EL SALVADOR, ONE-THIRD OF ALL
EL SALVADOR ENDS ON THE PLANET
LIVE IN THE UNITED STATES.
ONE-THIRD OF ALL EXISTING
SALVADORANS.
PHILLY EVERYTHING WE'VE DONE FOR
SALVADOR HASN'T STOPPED THE FLOW
OF ONE-THIRD OF THE ENTIRE
POPULATION INTO OUR COUNTRY.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
WHY DON'T WE SAY LOOK, WE'RE
GOING TO PUNISH YOU PERSONALLY
IF YOU LET THIS CONTINUE, WHY IS
THAT A BAD IDEA?
>> WE HAVEN'T GIVEN VERY MUCH
MONEY TO CENTRAL AMERICA.
KEEP IN MIND, WE GIVE ABOUT 1%
OF OUR BUDGET OVERALL IN FOREIGN
AID AROUND THE WORLD.
A VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF THAT GOES
TO CENTRAL AMERICA.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
WHY DO WE GIVE ANY?
ONE-THIRD OF ALL SALVADORANS
LIVE IN OUR COUNTRY A LOT OF
THEM ILLEGALLY AND I'M SURE
THEY'RE ALL GREAT PEOPLE, I'M
NOT ATTACKING THEM.
I'M SAYING THIS ARRANGEMENT
ISN'T WORKING.
THEY ARE OFF-LOADING THEIR POUR
INTO OUR COUNTRY AT A TIME WHEN
WORKING-CLASS JOBS ARE GOING
AWAY DUE TO AUTOMATION, THEIR
BENEFIT AND, WE ARE LOSING AND
PAYING THEM.
>> I JUST EXPLAIN THAT TO YOU.
THE REASON WE ARE GIVING AID IS
TO HELP IMPROVE THOSE COUNTRIES
SO THAT PEOPLE STAY -- THAT'S
THE LONG TERM GOAL.
I THINK YOU AND I BOTH AGREE IT
WITH THAT AS DO MANY
POLICYMAKERS IN WASHINGTON.
WE HAVEN'T DONE A GOOD ENOUGH
JOB.
NEITHER DEMOCRATS NOR
REPUBLICANS HAVE DONE A GOOD
ENOUGH JOB OF HELPING THESE
COUNTRIES IMPROVE THEIR
ECONOMIES, HELPING THESE
COUNTRIES IMPROVE THE RULE OF
LAW SO PEOPLE DON'T LEAVE.
>> Tucker: IS NOT TRUE.
MEXICO HAS JUMPED MORE THAN TEN
SPOTS ON THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT LIST
INTERNATIONALLY.
I THINK IS NOW NUMBER 11.
WE'VE MADE MEXICO RICH WITH
TRADE.
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, MILLIONS OF JOBS.
AND YET WE STILL HAVE 22 MILLION
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, THE MAJORITY OF THE
MEXICAN.
I'M NOT ATTACKING MEXICO OR
MEXICAN PEOPLE, I'M SAYING WE'VE
MADE IN MEXICO RICHER THAN IT
WAS AND WE STILL HAVE AN INFLOW
FROM MEXICO.
WE'RE NOT GETTING ANYTHING OUT
OF THIS.
>> THAT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE.
YES WE ARE BECAUSE FAR LESS
IMMIGRANTS ARE COMING FROM
MEXICO RIGHT NOW.
YOU REFER TO IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE
ALREADY HERE FROM MEXICO MANY OF
WHOM CAME A LONG TIME AGO.
BEFORE THE BENEFITS OF NAFTA
WENT IN PLACE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA WE DON'T
GET MANY IMMIGRANTS FROM MEXICO.
EVEN YOUR EXAMPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY IS MIGRANTS FROM
HONDURAS, NOT FROM MEXICO.
THERE ENJOYING THE BENEFITS OF
NAFTA IN CANDIDLY SUPPORTING
THEIR FAMILIES.
IT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE.
>> Tucker: SINCE YOU YEARS AND
THE DATA, LET ME REFER YOU TO
THE ESSENTIAL DATUM IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
WE HAVE MORE THAN 10 MILLION
MEXICAN CITIZENS LIVING IN OUR
BORDERS ILLEGALLY, ONCE AGAIN
I'M NOT ATTACKING THEM, BUT IF
THE MODEL YOU'RE PROPOSING WORKS
AND WE BOTH KNOW THAT IT DOESN'T
IT'S ALL A JOKE, IT'S A HUGE LIE
THE WHOLE POINT IS TO MAKE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MORE POWERFUL,
LET'S PLAY ALONG -- IF YOUR
MODEL WORKS THEN WHY ARE THEY
STILL HEAR?
WHY HAVEN'T THEY GONE BACK TO
THE NEWLY ENRICHED MEXICO WHICH
WE ENRICHED WITH OUR MONEY AND
OUR JOBS.
>> MANY CAME FROM A LONG TIME
AGO.
THE DATA I'M REFERRING TO IS A
LEGAL IMMIGRATION FROM MEXICO
HAS GONE DOWN, YOU AGREE WITH ME
ON THAT RIGHT?
>> Tucker: I'M MISSING IT.
THE DATA AS YOU SAID SHOW THAT
MEXICO IS WAY RICHER THAN IT WAS
20 YEARS AGO.
WE DID THAT, WE SUFFERED AS A
RESULT OF THAT BUT WE ALSO GOT
ALL OF THEIR POOR PEOPLE WHO
THEY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE SUPPORTING
WITH THEIR NONEXISTENT SOCIAL
SAFETY NET SO THEY CAN MAKE MORE
BILLIONAIRES WHICH THEY HAVE
ASSIDUOUSLY DONE.
WE GET SHAFTED, WE ARE PAYING
FOR THE HEALTH CARE OF THEIR
POOREST PEOPLE YOU DON'T SEE
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT AT ALL?
>> YOUR POINT DOESN'T MAKE SENS
SENSE.
WERE TALKING ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND IT HAS GONE DOWN
FOR MEXICO.
IT COULD GO DOWN FOR HONDURAS
AND GUATEMALA AND OTHER
COUNTRIES IN CENTRAL AMERICA
JUST AS WE HELPED IMPROVE THOSE
ECONOMIES.
WE ONLY GET A LITTLE BIT OF
MONEY, LET'S HELP IMPROVE THOSE
ECONOMIES.
>> Tucker: WE NEED TO PAY
MORE.